I I don't know. I feel like so gas lit about this guy who [laughter]
>> Hutch, it's time to fall in love with Graham Platner.
But [laughter] >> Hutch, I need you to accept that no matter
how many people Grand Platner, you're going to say vote for him.
This is no matter who in its purest form. Okay, vote for Grand
Platner. No, we need we need to get rid of this
Thank [music] you. Thank you. We need to do Lib and learn first.
I have a 20-minute section on platiner. We're going to do live
and learn here. Let me find my timestamp. Like, hm, I don't know,
guys. Like, maybe we shouldn't like fall prey to these sorts
of like pure like we we should like kick that out of the party.
And and Guy was the one who was like, "Guys, look, we got to
stick through it." And I'm on Guy's team now. I'm like, "All
right, this whatever. We're winning. MAGA f I don't care who
he cheated on, what his tattoo says. Like, get them the out."
Uh, so yeah, I'm fully on board now. This is this is dark woke.
All right.
I mean, they're going to spend a lot of money in the state of
Maine. So, uh, the first ad that Collins came out with today
is voters reading his old Reddit post where he calls like Maine
workingass people stupid and racist. [laughter] And it's like,
>> okay, but >> you know, think you're >> Sorry,
it's very funny. >> He didn't say main working-class people,
did he? I thought he said, didn't he say it was like Oh, it was
like racist. Was it just rural Americans? I thought it was like
Republicans or something or Southerners or some [__]
like that. >> Financial position. >> Did he just
Did he say man or did he say rural? Okay, that's kind of funny.
I Dude, the funniest part about that to me
is that he's literally like a rural manor. [laughter]
He's telling himself a little thanks to Trump's tariffs and his
never- ending war in Iran. These are things that matter a million
times more to people than a dude posting on Reddit and being
rough with some ex-girlfriends supposedly. Don't you agree?
>> It could be. I mean, I Dude, dude, this is awesome.
I
his prime directive is kicked in in a way that we finally agree
with. We're going to have We're going to have a ally in IRI today.
What?
[laughter] What?
Yeah. people care more about the politics of the country than
him being rough with some girlfriends supposedly.
That's actually true. As much as I I almost do wish it were otherwise.
I wish people actually did care about these personal I think
politics would be better if people cared about this. I'm not
joking. It would be better. Matter a million times more to people
than a dude posting on Reddit and being rough with some ex-girlfriends
supposedly. Don't you agree?
>> It could be. I mean, I I wouldn't bet my life that he
loses, but I just don't feel confident. And, you know, the other
logic that I have is that I think it's just kind of insane to
think that there are not going to be more stories that are going
to come out about this guy and that he's just not going to be
just I I don't know. I feel like so gaslit about this guy who
>> kind of like [laughter] like everyone that pretended
like I feel like at each step of the way it's like a diver acclimating
to a new depth, [snorts] you know, like the there's like a cadence
to these stories where the first story was kind of embarrassing.
>> I don't think so. I actually don't think they've gone
into a linear fashion at >> The Reddit post, but that was
not enough for me to withdraw support. I still liked him as a
candidate. >> He said he wanted to fight in the American
Indian Wars where there was a >> dude. THE YEAH, HOLD ON.
PEACE GOES IT. EXACTLY. BRO, SOME OF THE MOST DIS some of the
most disqualifying is in the Reddit post unironically.
He's like just talking about how much he wants to kill people.
That's some of the most disqualifying out of everything. And
Hutch is like, "Wow, that didn't really bother me at all." His
deep personal thoughts on how he really thought he was like the
ultimate killer and how he would fight in other wars so he could
like go people his bare hands. That didn't hit you. That didn't
hit you. It's like, "Oh, this guy's like a crazy person. What
the hell?" >> Genocide. [laughter] >> Well, one,
he called them the Indian Wars. Two, no one asked which one you
wanted. Three, [laughter] like, why don't you pick the one where
no one died? You know, like what what's going on, buddy? >> Wait,
didn't he Hold on.
Wait. When it was the Indian Wars, I thought it was literally
like, "If you could be in any war, which one would it be or something?"
I thought that's what it was.
No. Am I crazy? Is that not I thought that was the question was
literally like, "What war would you most like to fight in?" Or
did he just like go to a random thread and answer that? What's
your biggest fantasy in the world? What What if you could do
anything? If you could be anywhere, any point in time, what would
you do? I'd go back and fight in the Indian Wars on the side
of the Cowboys.
[laughter] >> Sorry, Hut. Sorry to interrupt you. Go Bro,
it'd be it might be even crazier if he said on the side of the
Indians. I think we could have turned it. I think I think if
I was there, we could have turned it. >> Long story short,
I mean, like this conversation should have been over the second
we found out he had a Nazi tattoo. Like, obviously, this should
have been over
>> day one. Like, okay, this is not someone that we should
go with to go up against Susan Collins. But people
dug their heels in and doubled down and tripled down. And >> Hutch
thinks that like all of the 50-year-old white ladies in Maine
are like unironically mainlining Ryan Grim, Crystal Ball, Sam
Cedar, Hassan [__] I don't think so, man. I'm guessing
that if you were to look at the analytics for all of those content
creators, their views in terms of Maine are like zero. I don't
think anybody in Maine gives a about what those people say. So
you could say, well, all these people gas lit. All these people
did all this. Yeah, they didn't do anything. This guy had a message
that did connect with the voters of Maine. That's the biggest
thing. You keep complaining about getting gas lit. It's like,
dude, the voters picked the guy. They picked the guy they wanted.
What else are we supposed to do? What are we supposed to say
about that? >> Quadrupled down. And, you know, I'm just
seeing some pretty crazy defenses of him. And I'm seeing people
that have presented as progressive for years now saying that
we can disqualify allegations from Republicans, which is like
I at that point I feel like you've just shredded all your credibility
if you're taking that position. Um >> that's what Pisco
was saying is like when that happened, we were all like, "All
right, guys. This guy's got horrible judgment. Like we should
go with the safer candidate." And this >> I I endorsed
uh I endorsed Platner over >> I was a Mills fan all the
way, man. I'm sad. I think the judgment thing on Mil >> I
think basically the people who went with Platner early on were
people who were like yeah Janet Mills is old as Janet Mills was
literally retiring. That's why she wasn't going to be the governor
again. That's why she wasn't running in the governor's race cuz
she's retiring. Like like she's too old for this. She's objectively
said okay I bow I bow out I'm too old for this.
That's why Janet Mills was a bad candle part is that she's super
old and like probably she had promised that she was gonna retire.
I wanted to bring that up or something. >> Soy pill because
someone said on the debate panel, I don't know if it was to you
or to Hutch. >> Does this bear on Schumer? I forget who
said this, but there was >> Oh god. >> Someone was
like Schumer picked uh Mills and there were these other vibrant
candidates that were available.
>> Who said that? I forget. And what was your response?
>> Jolola. It was Jolola, I think. >> Oh, that's
right. Jul smart kid that >> No, he's right. He's right.
>> Yeah, people have a right to be pested Schumer. Wait
a second. >> What other vibrant candidates? Who did he
mention? >> I don't remember. Some Jordans girl. >> There
are none. There's none. >> There's Maine, dude. It's nobody.
>> Do not come at my manners. Do not ever.
>> no. The point is is that he, you know, Schumer stepped
in and and >> What do you mean it's Maine?
I mean, I was just making the same point. I really can't I really
can't pass the first stone on this one, can I? >> Made
sure that the field was was was cleared. And you know, like on
I think like if this was like four years ago, Mills would have
been fine. But after Biden, people, especially Democratic Party
voters, are a little freaked out by older voters and and and
just like the clash of Mills and Platner, that was just like
he set her up to fail. Like she she didn't get any support from
the party after she entered that race. That's kind of crazy.
And so like, you know, yeah, to a certain extent they bear some
responsibility. I'm frustrated with the main voters like for
sticking with this guy after all this. You know, that's that's
pretty frustrating. I'm frustrated with him as a candidate. I'm
frustrated with like all the people online that have propped
this candid candidacy up despite like a thousand red flags. But
>> that's really what it is unfortunately for Hutch. Like
he could say these other things. It's not I swear to God it's
not even
the actual red flags of the conduct. And he's almost said as
much. It's like just the people online who keep supporting him.
That's why he doesn't like Grand Platner. If if Han [__]
and Kyle Kolinsky and Crystal Ball had never mentioned Grand
Plat, Hutch would be quietly blue no matter who. He would be
soft defending Grand Platner all over the place. It wouldn't
even be a thought or a concern for him. It is
so crazy to me that this is the way it is.
I'm frustrated with him as a candidate. I'm frustrated with like
all the people online that have propped this candid candidacy
up despite like a thousand red flags. But, you know, best case
scenario, he makes an incent, these scandals don't matter. He's
learned his lesson and he kills it with policy, right? Like that
could happen. I'm not saying it's the the most likely outcome
based on his past judgment, but like these people clearly are
like judging him based on what he's saying he's going to do,
not on like he's not running on being an abuser. He's not running
on the Nazi tattoo. That's not his platform. >> Soy was
one of the uh the ex partners of the New York Times profiled
as part of their piece. >> Wow. He >> come on. Soyill
was Soy Pill was breaking into Grant Platner's house. >> He's
a great speaker. He resonates with people. I mean I really encourage
people to check out his speech like on Friday where Roana was
there. He he knows how to connect with people, man. And he's
got a great message. So I wouldn't be surprised if he shines
in the Senate. >> He does. >> Dude, do they talk
do they talk about Roana's speech? I wonder if if that speech
hit any of them the same way it hit me that I was like, "Oh,
I actually think Roana I didn't think very much of Roana." I
knew he was like trying to make a name for himself. I know that
he's got aspirations for higher office, but to me that speech
hit is like, "Oh, he's got aspirations for higher office and
like immediate aspirations." I'm almost positive that he is looking
at a 2028 campaign. >> I want to pre Go ahead. Sorry. >> No,
you go. >> I was going to say I want to preempt some things
for Hutch. All right. And I want to give the arguments ahead
of time because we know we're going to hear all this from the
dirt bag left going after Hutch on this point. So I want to lay
it out here. If there's future hand ringing by Democrats post
primary who are like, "Oh, Platiner, whatever. I don't know if
I'll endorse. Maybe he's the lesser of two evils." If that happens,
will it be the same [laughter] as the hand ringing by dirt bag
leftists prior to 2024?
>> This is actually what I was looking for was just basically,
okay, it's the same thing is what happened with Camala.
It is. It is objectively the same thing that you've been running
wild on people about for months, Hutch. It's the same. It has
to You have to consider it the >> If not the same, why
not the same? And regardless of if of if it is the same, is it
justified to do hand ringing after the primary? >> Let
me show you what I think is like the perfect way to handle the
platiner thing. There's a video of AO >> that No. No, that's
not your answer. That's not your answer, Hutch. What is your
answer, Hutch? >> She commenting on it. And I think this
should just be the standard line from Democrats. You know, you
don't have to lie about this guy. You don't have to minimize
the concerns that people have. You don't need to pretend like
there are not a thousand obvious red flags,
but you you can just go with this and like this is fine. Like
you don't need to tie your fortunes to this guy in the way that
I'm seeing other people do. >> All right, let's see this.
>> Obviously, there's a lot in that. Obviously, there's
a lot in that behavior that's really challenging. It's hard to
stomach, you know, in some of it. But but at the end of the day,
I think that this is a choice. If the choice on the ballot is
between that and a senator who's voted to take healthcare away
from millions of Americans,
>> that's the situation that we have to
>> That by the way, if Hutch was doing this in the first
place, if Hutch had ever done exactly what AOC is doing here,
I would have no problem with Hutch's rhetoric. Hutch can admit
that this is not at all what he's been doing, right? Like, okay,
I I'm not super happy. Like I do think you could be a little
stronger than this and just like it's crazy that we're allowing
somebody to make comparisons when this is the other candidate.
This is what the other party's doing, right? Like I don't know
about the behavior, but also one it's up to mayors to decide
on that. And two, like look at the behavior on the other side.
Really, we're not even we haven't even entered the same stratosphere
as this party like to our right. Okay, so please miss me with
the hand ringing.
I would like that a little bit more from AOC, but realistically,
if Hutch was talking like this, I wouldn't have a problem. The
problem is that he never even gets to Susan Collins in any way.
I've barely heard Hutch talk about Susan
>> All right. Yeah, that's that's that's perfect. Like,
yeah, this is this guy's awful. You know what? He's also going
to give millions of people healthcare. Better options. >> Is
that perfect? >> Would you accept that in 2024? Yeah, >> I
just wish people wouldn't try to make excuses that he's >> that's
by the way also that is literally
Kyle Kolinsky. That is the Kyle Klinsky response in 2024. That's
it right there. One to one. So Hutch has to give up now that
he said that's I would have been accepting of that. Okay, stop
talking about Kyle Klinsky in 2024.
>> He's not lying or challenging the women. Like it's okay
to say he's lying. I mean I I don't know. I don't you know people
lie. I I don't lie. I'm sure people would think I do, but I don't
lie, but I'm also not under a microscope about my past relationships
and embarrassed about not getting a tattoo removed years ago.
So, I I have no idea. You don't You don't have a lot of reasons
to lie, guy, I'm assuming, right? So, like maybe let's put ourselves
in his shoes. Let's all get Nazi tattoos and then cover them
up and see how hard it is to do that. Like, can we have some
empathy for the guy? Well, I and I I think Trump proved that
you can you can lie and and uh with impunity and it's not the
end of the world. I mean, people voted for Trump to save a few
dollars at the grocery store. That's it. I mean, that's decision
making that's going on nowadays with >> But the reason
that's not the same piece, go is like is it is the problem that
people had with like the dirt bag left that they criticized Kamla
or was it their specific criticisms of Kamla? You know, >> I
Yeah. So here's the issue with that, right? So I do think that
there's like a difference in opinion on the underlying criticism
for sure that you can say there's a more plausible case for this
versus that. I think that that's one way that you could try to
distinguish what's going on here. But often time how those conversations
would develop is that libs were in a kind of a more
maybe this speaks to all libs accommodating position where they
were like sure sure whatever you want to say but vote for him
anyway or like I know I kind of agree with you on this or that
and so whether or not now it's all well and good to say that
there's a difference in terms of who's right or wrong on the
policy but at the time it very much seemed like the the attempt
to win over the left was kind of like yes yes you're kind of
right. You're sort of right, but vote for her anyway. Listen,
I'm not saying that I endorse that and I say they're equal on
all accounts, but what do you think of that? >> I feel
like I'm Are you asking me specifically here? >> Yeah.
Yeah. That Liv's kind of uh they were kind of like, you're right.
The policy is horrible and and Biden is doing a bad job on Israel,
but you still >> That's not what I said. I don't think
that's what most people were saying. No, I think I think most
people were frustrated that the left was like taring taring and
feathering Kla and you know you know accusing her of being like
complicit in a genocide and calling her like cop Mala. They've
they've hated her since the 2020 primaries. So you know
like I if if Why does Pisco cuddle him? I don't Well, because
if Pisco attack if Pisco like is forceful in this conversation
in any way, Pisco has to deal with harassment of his own. That's
why Pisco cuddles. That's why Pisco has to go very slowly and
just not really deal with Yeah. He Pisco can't have an honest
conversation on this podcast. Well, none none of them can.
So, if any of them said like anytime I heard one of them say
like, "Look, I disagree with her ideologically. She, you know,
I I prefer somebody to my left, but you know, obviously it's
important that she beat Donald Trump." I have no problem with
people saying that. It's when people smeared her the way that
they did. I'm not smear >> I IOP asks okay what's your
problem with Kolinsky then who did overwhelmingly positive coverage
of Kamla overwhelmingly negative coverage of Trump and basically
argued that his vote viewers should vote switch or vote trade
right if they're in a blue state or if they're in a red state
if no they're in a a state where their vote mattered right or
didn't matter like do vote swapping if you want to do some kind
of protest vote you can't have a problem with Kolinsky's conduct
in the 2024 election and maintain this position >> miring
planner by pointing out that this >> that he has a Nazi
>> bone head and he is playing the victim. Like, doesn't
that make you kind of a little bit irritated to hear him complain
that people are looking into his past? Like, you're a Senate
candidate. This is like part of the job, you know? Is it complaining
or is it descriptive? Like maybe he's pointing it out that like
stuff's coming out because you are they are digging into my past,
but I knew that would happen. He literally the time I remember
him talking about it is well they're they're going through my
past with a fine tooth comb because I'm a senator right be and
I knew this was going to be the case when I signed up. Amy and
I knew this would be the case. We didn't think it would get to
this point but we're we're still here. We knew this was going
to be a consequence. That's how I've heard him talk about it.
Right. >> You're asking the voters for a lot of trust to
give you a lot of power. they have a right to know what is in
your past and what kind of character you have and he's treating
that as though >> it's a violation of his privacy and I
just I just don't like that kind of
attitude or that rhetoric. >> Yeah. No, I I I don't like
his attitude at all. Um I I think that the frustration that some
people feel is and certainly I feel for a lot of people in the
runup to 2024 is the calculation aspect of it. Regardless of
how correct the criticism was, I I mean like you could make even
if it were correct, whatever criticism that you're talking about
of Kla or Biden, I would still be pissed at the calculation.
That's kind of what I'm I'm driving at. And and similar things
kind of here. Now, another thing way to distinguish is like the
presidency is way more important than one little you guys kind
of had that exchange in the debate, too, where it's well, it's
just one senator, right? Who who cares about one senator? I think
all of us here are convinced that the Senate is of huge significance
and importance to uh the Democrats ambitions and plans, not just
in the interim period, but also for the uh 2028 >> Yeah.
What could be the difference between, you know, ending a filibuster
or having a majority on a vote like that's going to matter. It's
not one house vote. It's not one local election. Um, but I guess
Hutch, I think people probably will have more smoke for us if
we were like to continue the like playing up all this and like
covering the stories and like, you know, otherwise dragging them
down if it's like a week before the general because you're allowed
to look at all that stuff and say, "Yeah, that's that's horrible
and yet you should still vote for it." Because what Pisco is
saying about the comm situation is you don't have to be happy
about what she's doing in Gaza. You don't have to be happy that
she's not doing Medicare for all. But what you're doing is you're
saying, "I don't want to vote for this person, and I'm going
to tell all my constituents not to vote for this person, which
is going to get you Trump. And if you want that, go vote for
that." Okay? But that's not what I want. I can say this are the
>> dude why I I just feel like I just watched soy pill
be so effective in telling somebody who doesn't have a good opinion
who is acting like a [__] that they're acting like
a [__] and that they need to shut the up or like
he's so good at distilling stuff down and now he's talking to
Hutch and we're taking this roundabout
to like just making the point of
hey like obviously we should stop just like pure negative coverage
of him without highlighting the differences between him and Collins
like it should always be a comparison between Platner and Collins.
If you're going to cover Platner's downside,
if you if your goal is to get people to vote for him anyway,
you want to you want to acknowledge the downside while getting
people to vote for him, you should be saying, "Yes, this is bad.
I still don't think this comes close to anything Susan Collins
will support, has supported, right?" And and it's just like all
of this it's just this crazy
circumnavigation of the obvious point to not hurt Hutch's feelings
every time. >> Things that she's going to do that are better.
This is how Platin is going to make this country better. And
yeah, Susan Colin, she's going to take your healthcare away.
She's going to appoint another Kavanagh, right? So >> it
depends on like how soon before the general you're doing it versus
in the primary, like I said, like this is the time. But since
Mills dropped out, I feel like what it's wasted breath honestly.
like he's just going to be >> I I think Hutch it's time
to fall in love with Graham Platner. But >> dude,
oh when I now I get how some people like IRI cuz when IRI is
on your side, it doesn't even matter. Hutch, I need you to accept
that no matter how many people Grand Platin,
you're going to say vote for him. Hutch, say it right now. This
is this is the blue no matter who in its purest form. Okay. I
doesn't give a how many intruders this guy. Doesn't give a how
many women he smacked around. Vote for Grant Plutner. No, we
need we need to get rid of this filibuster. Get some meaningful
legislation through. It's It's just very funny. Okay, I'm just
I'm telling you, it's funny. >> I'm not going to I'm not
[laughter] going to do that. >> You got to >> No,
I don't. >> You got to You will never feel safer in your
house than if Grant Platin is there. You got to fall in [laughter]
love with him. >> I never told lefties that they needed
to pretend to like, you know, like the Democrat that's on their
ballot. I never said that. And I'm not going to
>> Biden's the candidate and you can't talk about how he's
old and and like cognitively declining. You can't do that. It's
like terrible. You're just working against him.
I Okay. Like come on, man. Come on. Come on. Hutch. >> I'm
not going to pretend like this guy [laughter] is I feel like
I'm being so ghastlit about this guy, man. Like really truly.
It should have been over as soon as the Nazi tattoo came out.
And I'm pissed about I'm salty about that. >> Okay. But
it's it's there. I'll say it right now
from all indications are
that IRI may actually love his country more than the other country
has citizenship in I which is crazy cuz I swear to God so much
of the time I hear somebody who is a liberal Zionist. It it feels
the other way. But I swear to God, IRI is basically saying, "No,
no, no. I want my party to have power. I want my party to have
power as soon as possible and get meaningful legislation through."
I'm willing to take an anti-ionist to do it. And I don't give
a I I think that's kind of interesting to be honest with you.
I wouldn't have expected that. I think that's a little interesting.
>> So much good about him that it's better to focus on
that than the negative in my opinion. Like this guy is advocating
for good policy. he is connecting and resonating with voters.
He could be a huge injection of energy in our party that inspires
people to vote for Democrats across the board. I think it's better
to look at the positive. And that's why I say it's time to fall
in love with him because why not focus on
>> instead of his [laughter] stupid lies that he's probably
embarrassed about with his wife that has nothing to do with anything
else and the tattoo that he's probably embarrassed he should
have got it done earlier. Why not just focus on the positive?
>> Yeah. Listen,
I think, >> dude, it's crazy. It's crazy that IRI is saying
this right now. IRI is making the Dude, Ira is the guy who will
always have Hutch's back when he goes down like these these blind
anti-lefty rabbit holes, okay? Cuz broadly the lefties are fairly
critical of the Dem Party. So, usually I will align with them
one to one. Now he's lost his I buffer, okay? There's no more
IRI buffer there of IRI just being like, "Yeah, man. I just love
the Democrats.
It's gone. What is Hutch going to do? with peace and love in
my heart. You're creating like a silver lining here that doesn't
exist. Like the suggestion that he's going to be a boon to the
party is a bit absurd to me right now because like other Democratic
senators, >> he has an actual Nazi tattoo. Gas hits five
bucks. That Nazi tattoo is going to start pushing him up in the
polls. I Hutch, I I hate to tell you this, Hutch. As gas approaches
$5, that Nazi tattoo is going to become beneficial. It's going
to become a boon to the Democratic party. I hate to tell you
this, okay? I'm I'm honestly joking, but I'm only like 30% joking.
Okay, I'm only like 70% joking.
Like, honest to God, that Iran war as it drags out, as it gets
more expensive, as it continues to global supply chains, it's
just going to get worse. It's just going to make people hate
Israel more. It's that's how it's going to go.
I'm sorry. Did I say I meant hot? Yeah. Yeah. are being bombarded
with questions about this guy instead of focusing on like how
unpopular Donald Trump is. Like he's already dragging other candidates
that are running for office in this cycle. That's not he's not
a boon to the party right now. Like I I'm not I'm not really
seeing the upsides. Like has somebody asked him about like the
comparison between the Nazi tattoo versus backing a genocide?
Yes. Um
Josiah came on and and kind of grilled him on this and they didn't
do a follow-up and just he had no answer for Josiah. Yeah. are
of focusing on like how unpopular Donald Trump is. Like he's
already dragging other candidates that are running for office
in this cycle. That's not he's not a where
what do you mean? What? Who in the world is like, "Well, I would
vote for the Democrat in in Oregon, but actually the because
Democrats picked this Graham Platiner guy in Maine, I'm not going
to vote for this Democrat anymore. I actually have to go Republican.
There's nothing I could do. Where is that happening?
Fetman. There's no way he'd sight Federman off. >> Boon
to the party right now. Like I I'm not I'm not really seeing
the upsides like you know. >> Are are are other Democrats
swinging down the polls when his scandals drop? I don't know.
I haven't tracked this. >> Probably not like right now.
I mean, so why did you say that then?
Why did you just say that 5 seconds ago?
Hey, dummy.
You just said he's dragging other candidates already. And then
Soy Pill goes, "Oh, are Democrats dropping in the polls when
his scandals drop?" AND YOU GO, "OH, I don't know. Probably not
right now." Then why did you say it? Why the did you just say
that? You just making up? >> I don't know. It's just like,
you know, but but the point is like they're going on these news
shows. They should be talking about Donald Trump like literally
falling asleep in like every setting that he's been filmed in
for the last 3 weeks instead of talking about the um do they
not? Every time I've seen somebody bring up the platiner thing,
the the way you deflect the the platiner thing is by talking
about Donald Trump being a piece of
that's how you deflect the platiner thing.
What the are you talking about? I know on Hutch's program he
just talks about how Grant Platner sucks all the time. Maybe
he's just missed it, but that's the most effective way. You talk
about Susan Collins letting the hospitals get closed. You talk
about Donald Trump being I mean every matter every manner of
degenerate on planet Earth. He's corrupt. He's a liar. He's a
piece of he's he's a
he's you know at least somewhat close to being a okay based on
what you believe about the Epstein stuff. Like come on,
pick your poison on Donald Trump, man. disastrous economic policy,
the Iran war, the all of them are getting pressed on platiner
and we look like we
>> every single one of them. Hutch doesn't understand this
a weapon. Hey dummy. Hey egghehead, this is a weapon. You want
to talk about this guy cheating on his wife? One, the president
cheated on his wife. Two, the president his wife. Three, the
president started this war with Iran that's g making gas go to
450 right now. Hey. Hey, why are you asking me about this guy
texting some women? the wrong with you?
That's a weapon every single time you show how they don't believe
in the things they say they believe in.
>> You give up a bit of our credibility because we've been
attacking the Republican party for putting forward like really
bad immoral candidates for years and now we got to stretch ourselves
a bit to be accommodating to this guy. But as long as people
do the AOC strat, I think that's fine. Just I'm not going to
I'm not going to
>> Dude, are these Dude, Toy Pill, you need to understand
that Hutch
is just Tally Bots except instead of loving Israel, he hates
Assan. Okay, he's just Tallybots and you need to start treating
him like that because I swear to God there is just no other explanation
for the way he talks, for the things he says. It's you are so
good at stick at sticking it to Tally when she says something.
You do need to start being a little more hostile with this guy.
if he is going to be like this.
Like I know soyill understands. I know soyill because I watched
them do it a hundred times to tally bots. You're attacking ground
platner right now. Have you thought about how Trump is worse
in every possible way?
Why did you just let Hutch say, "Well, we can't talk about Trump
cuz people ask about Platner."
Okay. If people ask about Platner, you immediately say, "Why
are you asking me about Platner?" Trump,
that's the obvious. He knows the solution. I've watched him deploy
it. Why can't he explain it to Hutch right
>> People are patronizing people. I'm going to be upfront
and direct about >> the guy's problems and I'm still going
to I'm still going to emphasize at the end of all that that it's
really important that we win back the Senate because it is. >> I
don't know if you reposted that clip, Hutch, but there was it
with Bernie where he's like, you know, like are we going to talk
about, you know, his sex scandals? He's like, are we going to
talk about how the 1% like immediately deflects it to the economy
and it's like, yeah, that's like exactly what you're saying.
It's like if they're being asked questions about this guy, it
should take >> Okay, never mind. You know what? Soy pill,
you're all right, kid.
Hey, white boy. You're all right, white boy. Let's go. >> About
10 seconds or less to immediately redirected to the actual problems
that people care about. And yeah, that's like the probably the
best thing we can do going forward. >> There's always going
to be somebody bad out there. Like, you're never going to have
a perfect slate of candidates. And if this guy is as bad as he
gets for us versus like Ken Paxton, then we're golden. And I
tell you, the Democrats are crafty. They've already come up with
some talking points that the other ones need to take in instead
of getting all weird like Roan is saying, "Yeah, he's messed
up because of these wars that Susan Collins voted for that sent
him to like a lot of people in America."
>> He volunteered guy >> Hutch Hutch is going to
get Hutch is going to lose it on II for the sweep right here.
>> Okay. [laughter]
Okay. But >> I know what you're saying. >> Yeah.
The point is that a lot of people in America got messed up by
these wars that people like Susan Collins voted for and maybe
they volunteered to go back because that's all they knew. But
also he had access to that is quite literally why he went back.
I'm not even joking. Like there is an argument that it wasn't
that he liked. It was that like maybe that was the only place
he'd ever found where he was like welcomed and accepted and excelled
and that's what he knew. That's like the life he knew. There
are people who unironically describe this feeling with prison.
Like people will they'll go to prison and they won't be able
to operate in the world anymore once they get out of prison,
right? They don't understand the world. They don't understand
where they fit into it. They feel incredibly alienated and they
will reaffend because they know that if they go back to prison,
that's a world they understand. That's a world where they can
fit in. >> I'm just saying there's a way to spin this stuff
in a positive way and and not focus on the negative. I'm not
telling you what to do, Hutch. I'm just saying what good does
it do to even be on the fence about Graham Platner? >> I'm
not on the fence about him at all, you know, and I'll stress
that every time I talk about him.
>> I will defend you in the sense that and you might have
saw like I get upset when people are pulling out the like MAGA-es
defenses where it's like she's just lying and like you know don't
get me wrong some of these accusers might be lying. I'm always
skeptical. >> I would never say she's just lying because
she's a Republican or she's just lying because she's a woman.
But I would say she probably lying about this one at least in
so far as she feels like she was physically abused. >> But
the way that the sweeping is happening where it's like this guy's
golden. He's never done anything wrong. All of this is a >> Nobody
is saying that. Literally nobody has said that. You're trying
to help Hutch because you are you're just literally making something
up. What? I did Kyle even say this?
Did Kyle even go this far? Who is Soy Pill talking about? This
guy never did anything. He didn't do nothing, guys. Who's Den
doing Graham Platner right now? What the is he talking about?
Hey, soy pill, what
bill? What the are you talking about, man?
Breaking points. incredibly empathetic to the woman, talking
explicitly about how they don't doubt her story, how they feel
like probably there was a really bad relationship there, which
I would agree with, by the way, but I've not seen anybody talk
like that. You're like validating Hutch's
right now for no reason. What the hell? >> I will defend
you in the sense that, and you might have saw like I get upset
when people are pulling out the like MAGA-es defenses where it's
like she's just lying and like, you know, don't get me wrong,
some of these accusers might be lying. I'm always skeptical and
you can wait until more evidence comes out. But the way that
the sweeping is happening where it's like this guy's golden.
He's never done anything wrong. All of this is a smear. And it's
like this feels like magense to me. That stuff does get me. I'm
like look guys, you can just say he's not perfect. I want him
to win anyway. But the fact that it's like no, it's actually
all a conspiracy to drag him down. And I'm like, >> I agree
with that as as stated soy bill. But I do think it's relevant
that this woman is like either working for or affiliated with
like the Heritage Foundation and half a dozen other Republican
organizations. And I think people do should should know that,
right? And she she joked about um >> I'm going to campaign
for Susan Collins. Now she maintains it was a joke or some message
of that. >> Bro, she's quite literally from the time he
basically was exploring his campaign was like, I can't let this
guy win now.
H man, I'm sorry. It is what it is, man. She's she's given you
all the information. There are just people who don't want to
accept it.
And there are lots of different reasons they don't want to accept
it. I fully believe that a lot of the people who have all this
information, like Ryan Grim, I fully believe that it's only on
a principled stance against ever like discounting a victim that
he won't just do it outright. I truly believe that Ryan Ry, sorry,
did I say Ryan Graham? Ryan Grim. and maybe even uh maybe even
Crystal Ball. I think that they fully believe that she's lying,
but they are on a principled ground not willing to say that because
they don't want to dismiss her outright and cause like that level
of turmoil. You know what I mean? I I think they fully believe
she's lying and they're just being empathetic otherwise. Like
they're just being empathetic with a lot of the other >> effect,
but I think that that's relevant when we're considering u you
know how much to to give credence to what she >> Yeah.
Yeah. And and I I'm sympathetic to the like you look at her specific
backstory and it's like all right there is some incentive for
you to be lying, but I think the degree to which How hard is
it for Hutch to go to his show with all the people he respects,
all of his friends, and then they just say all the things the
Meme Penguin said to him, all the things the Meme Penguin said.
Isn't that that must be up, right? Or they're just echoing the
Meme Penguin. Everyone echoing the mean penguin that's mean to
him. Come on, man. Why do you guys copy the penguin? The penguin's
an people will pick it apart is only happening because they like
platiner. In the same way that the MAGA people will be like,
"Oh, someone accused Barack Obama of like having gay sex with
his assistant I'm questioning will post this all over Facebook.
Oh, Donald Trump has been credibly accused of like a severe assault."
Nah, I don't know. Like that's that woman. Why didn't she come
out for 20 years? You know, it's like it's it's the the team
sports thing that really bothers me. Are you bothered by people
doubting the gay sex Obama story or Tara Reed for Biden? >> Are
you talking about me right now? >> So Bill, I'm grilling
soy bill right >> Well, the Tara Reed thing is is interesting.
If you look, >> dude, [laughter] Hutchfield's under attack.
Soy Bill Pisco doing some jokes back and forth that Hutchfield's
under attack right now. >> This is funny. >> Yeah,
I don't know. Like that's that woman. Why didn't she come out
for 20 years? You know, it's like it's it's the the team sports
thing that really bothers me. Wait, were you bothered by people
doubting the gay sex Obama story or Tara Reed for Biden? >> Are
you talking about me right now? >> The soy bill? I'm grilling
soy bill right now. >> Well, the Tara Reed thing is is
interesting. If you look at all the people doing the Platiner
thing right now, go back to their Tara Reed uh >> Okay,
that's a hypocrisy pivot. That's a hypocrisy. That's a hypocrisy
pivot. And I get that. And I also get it, by the way, on the
tattoo stuff with the Ukraine angle. I totally accept that. That's
a you know, also hypocrisy critique. I'm talking about you though.
I'm talking about you. Was I on the ter? I didn't actually pay
attention to the terror stuff, but I bet if I were No, wait.
Let me >> I didn't hear about that. I didn't hear about
that. >> If I If I were to go back and look at it, I would
assume that like this was some sort of like it looked kind of
smeary to me, but I didn't look into it. And had I looked into
it, it would have been I I remember it being like a little not
so credible or something, but I don't know. >> So So many
problems with Tara Reed and those allegations. >> Why would
you step into this, dude? Why would why does he keep stepping
on these landmines?
Like what kind of problems? Like an ideological commitment in
the other direction like like a lack of substantiation for some
of the most egregious claims. Like anybody can look up a Vox
article called the agonizing tale of Terara Reed and it's like
a six page, you know, article that details all the problems and
and like >> have you ever been consistent Hutch? >> Need
I hold on? >> Need I remind you guys [laughter] she [__]
>> the ultimate skeptic. She defected to Russia where she
is now a literal Russian propagandist and on her way there or
after she got there she accused Joe Biden and Interpole of trying
to murder her. Okay, this is a woman who wrote an erotic love
letter to Vladimir Putin. Okay, so like he's literally by the
way he's literally just attacking her reputation instead of dealing
with the fact that like at the time for the allegations when
they were made this stuff wasn't out. Like what if that allegation
were true? Don't you think it would start to feel like you're
being dismissed by everybody and it might lean like make you
lean towards more extreme behaviors that you're like being gaslit
that nothing happened like in the hypothetical where it is true?
Well, the initial allegation, right? >> Like it's just
not the same. And I I can understand some degree of skepticism
uh regarding the recent allegations, but you should note that
the New York Times couldn't find any connection to from this
woman to Susan Collins campaign. She insists that that was just
a joke. I don't think it's a good reason to just say, "Oh,
>> she didn't. She like political reasons could have led
to her doing this." But here's the thing. There are like four
or five writers who are friends with Lindsay Field who have positions
as journalists at other organizations
who all know how much she hates her ex-boyfriend Graham that
she rants about him constantly. He is a consistent topic of conversation
with her closest friends that he is a piece of that she was up
by him that she hates him. I'm telling you like it might not
be political but then when it is about this guy who's a total
piece of who she hates right
then suddenly all of her friends who are in politics know like
hey well we heard about this. Hey have you heard about this?
Hey, right. It's pretty easy to get her,
I guess, more or less on the the train of hating him, right?
Well, I don't know which way it went to be honest. She might
have heard all this information, her that he's running and gone,
"Haha, gals, we can take this guy down." I don't know which way
it went. If it was them passing information to her, her passing
information to them could be either way. >> Yeah, we can't
trust her. I certainly don't think it's a good reason to do what
Kyle Kolinsky did, which is basic, which he called her a lying.
He said uh like uh the difference between um Eene Carol's Eugene
Carol was telling the truth and and this woman is a lying Republican.
That's
bananas. Like that's wild. That's completely unacceptable. >> Yeah.
If if more substantiated things come out, you look so unhinged.
And so it's so fine to say, "Hey, I have reasons to not believe
this based on her connections." But to come out of the gate swinging
with 100% certainty, that's going to look really bad if there's
more. I don't think Kyle I the impression I get from Kyle is
not that he's 100% certain. The impression I get from Kyle is
that he's like fully embraced populism. And instead of saying
there's a couple reasons to doubt this woman's story. I think
maybe she's like a bit scorned and also she's against him politically,
he says this stupid lying is wrong and lying cuz she's a Republican
operative. a stupid [__] That's I that I hear those
and I like in terms of what I think of what Kyle Kolinsky knows
and if he knows something beyond what I know, well, no, I think
he knows about the same stuff I know and I think that's just
the way he talks right now. Is that a forgiveness? Is that like
a green light to say things that aren't true or or be way over
aggressive or way overconfident in the things you do actually
say? No, it's not. But I do think that there's some need for
that. People have different tasks. People have different talents.
And maybe Kyle's talent is being that that populist mouthpiece
that is just going to get people on p on the same page and go,
"Yeah, this stupid."
I personally disagree with it, but also I don't
at some point Democrats need to start winning the pleb vote.
Okay? You need to start winning the pleb vote at some point.
You're going for all the intellectuals. You're losing all the
plebs. The plebs love blood. The plebs love somebody who's gonna
call a sexual assault victim or sorry a physical assault victim
a stupid [__] which is
and really says a lot about the soul of not just America but
humanity and I'm not a huge fan of it but it is seeming to be
the way it is. >> I don't know I don't know what else to
say man. >> What else do you say? >> Agreed on that.
I think that the one person who has been consistent is Michael
Tracy. He doesn't believe any story no matter the proof. And
so that's that's important to uh to stress. >> Epste doesn't
even have a plane. It doesn't exist. [laughter] >> Yeah.
What What is uh sex trafficking after all? >> I think it's
funny the people that say like the only reason they're going
after him is because he's anti-Israel. It's like if you think
do you like let's just imagine if people found out that Cy Booker
had a Nazi tattoo? Like would the media not run that down and
cover that? Or it's not the Nazi tattoo. That's not the story
for the Nazi tattoo.
That's not what the story for the Nazi tattoo is. That could
be the story for the lie about the trying to point out that he
lied about the Nazi tattoo, right? Trying to show a big time
discrepancy in that lie. I think that could be like the backing
for that considering the source, considering where it was first
run. I do think there's some argument there. But in terms of
him having the Nazi tattoo and that being like a bad thing, everybody
agrees with that. If Cy Booker had been accused of physically
assaulting one of his former partners from 10 years ago, I would
not expect that story to run in the New York Times. I'm sorry.
That's just facts.
Anybody who disagrees with that, anybody who who thinks that
that story with the level of substantiation, with the level of
of substantiation and evidence they had, the level of the allegations
themselves and the person who was bringing the allegations, if
you think that story would have run in the New York Times, you're
out of your mind.
Those were it was TMZ level information, TMZ level substantiation
in the New York Times. I don't understand it. That's the concern,
right? It's not that it wasn't like it's not that it was inaccurate.
They say how little sourcing they have. They say how little they
were able to corroborate any of the information given. They say
that. But then if you're not able to corroborate any of it, is
that really up to your editorial standard? Like what is the public
interest then to go just letting you guys know somebody accused
him of this and there's not really any proof of it, but someone
accused him once.
Okay, that's the New York The New York Times going to run that.
The same publication
that had multiple sources in the room for major meetings about
the Iran war, major meetings between Trump and Netanyahu and
told that whole story masterfully in a massive profile after
the start of that
that goes in the same the same publication. What? How? How is
How are those comparable? How do those both go in the same publication?
That's wild to me. K. >> If Cy Booker had similar allegations
come out about him, do do these people really think that journalists
wouldn't aggressively pursue those stories? Or like any of these
stories, apply this to any other sitting member of Congress?
Like, do you really think that these journalists are running
these stories down because he's anti-Israel and not just because
he's just obviously problematic? But I don't know. I feel like
maybe we're circling the drain a little bit on this topic. >> Okay.
All right.
That was cool. That's the whole planner discussion. I man that's
that's very kid gloves for that whole discussion. But okay, very
very kid glovesy. I'm guessing Hutch will move away from this
topic entirely, right?
I do think that Hutch will move away from this. I think he he
knows how bad it would look if he doesn't. I do think Hutch will
move away from this.